The metropolitan police are
investigating
an officer-involved shooting Monday morning hello
how are you guys salud andrés gonzález with your
news nao briefing in
spanish this shooting happened
around 5am monday at the
apartment complex  boulevard is
located near nellis boulevard and vegas'
valley drive a suspect is dead
while officers were
injured and are being treated for
all the details you can visit
our page at disney.com the
Spanish section
once again long lines were seen for
a proof of  detection of food in the
site that was previously in journal vi and has
now moved to the sant boi stadium several
cars formed for the reopening of
this clinic in its new site this was
done in order to allow more
vehicles and better organization
to avoid
traffic congestion but this was not the case on
Sunday according to the health district there are
300 vaccines  and 1200 tests available
for each night on a first-come, first-served basis
however these sell out fast
the goal was clear win and you're
in last night the las vegas riders'
beat the los angeles chargers
and got their berth to the postseason
however it wasn't  an easy game the
chargers tied the game at the
last second and this forced that
time is the huayras got the
win thanks to a well executed field goal
due to damage and prison the bad guys
won 35 32
now we will see the weather forecast
we will have  Nice temperatures
with a sunny sky reaching a
high in the 60s for today we will see
some clouds pass by in the afternoon but it
won't be of great impact we will keep it in the
60s for the rest of the week have
a nice day I greet you at 3 gonzález
with your  brief informative of iu news now
in spanish